räuber und gangster gerade und
verbrecher wie ich sage hey herzlich
willkommen zu meinem heutigen video ich
studiere zusammen mit sebastian und wir
befinden uns ihr kennt wahrscheinlich
die hintergrund umgebung gar nicht im
winterurlaub und wahrscheinlich die auch
schon das in der ecke oben irgendwo
werbevideo steht das liegt daran dass
dieses video in kooperation zusammen mit
telecom genau oder mit magento tv
entstanden ist was genau man geld atv
ist esse ich euch später aber im namen
steckt ja schon tv das heißt es geht im
fernsehen serien und so weiter und aus
diesem grund dachte ich mir wir machen
heute einen serien intro talent das
heißt unsere kleine schwester spielt uns
über diese box die serien infos von
bekannten serien vor und wir gucken wer
von uns beiden sie schneller erwarten
kann das bin dann in der regel ich
wahrscheinlich fast okay habt ihr
könntet ihr erraten wir können glaube
ich ein bisschen lauter machen
das ist natürlich sehr gut zu unseren
urlaub hier
punkt eins geht an sebastian heidi ist
so eine richtige flashbacks serie oder
ein wenig für das über das intro an dich
geht es
und was ist das nein noch weitermachen
nur an spiel so an spielen dann können
wir bisschen überlegen und wenn wir da
nicht weiter kommen
okay gibt uns noch mal ein bisschen war
[Musik]
wie kommt das noch nicht so bekannt
heute
[Musik]
dass das irgendwie zudem oder pokemon
reihe ich habe mein erster gedanke war
auch die kümmern aber das ist es nicht
die gibt es tausende
ich habe keine ahnung aber high school
musical ich kann man bei uns darauf aber
es kommt mir so bekannt vor
das ist eine disney serien ich weiß ich
nicht mehr hinein
ich habe auch nicht gesagt habe diesen
song kennt doch jeder dass uns haben den
sebastian immer und überall hören
ich glaube ich war eine millisekunde da
ein bisschen schneller
alter schwede ein punkt für mich ich
würde sagen noch einen punkt und dann
gibt es die info das ist aber so was es
ist aber so was machen wir blamieren
ach ja erstmal das kommt mir so bekannt
vorhatte also wir in der ecke schon
lesen können ist das hier ein werbevideo
und ich wollte euch jetzt mal ein
bisschen was über magenta tv erzählen
also magenta tv hausen angebot von der
telekom das ist aber erstmalig nicht nur
für telekom kunden sondern jeder kann
mich das machen und was ist magento tv
überhaupt das ist ein wunderbarer ort im
internet der serien und live-tv
kombiniert also ihr könnt live fernsehen
egal wo ihr seid wir sind jetzt zum
beispiel gerade in österreich können
jetzt einfach hier an den laptop gehen
und können
deutsches live fernsehen schauen ohne
irgendwas wir brauchen einfach nur
internet zb gleichen gegen skifahren
kann ich einfach mich in der gondel
hinsetzen und fernsehen schon da sind
und hier haben wir auch meine absolute
lieblingsstadt schon mal yakari unsere
kleine schwester ist auch mega deswegen
dafür wie man frühjahr warten
ja wir sind auch immer carina wenn ich
mit 23 jahren sein kann ich also mit 14
auch japan seien aber ja also wir können
jetzt zum beispiel hier wenn wir
unterwegs sind im urlaub können wir
fernsehen und serien gucken aber genauso
gut geht das natürlich auch zu hause man
kann das auf cromcast auf smart tvs kann
man sich einfach das live fernsehen was
für mich speziell auch echt ne gute
sache ist weil ich bin nicht so der
intensive fernsehgucker aber es laufen
natürlich trotzdem immer mal wieder
sachen die man sich gerne anschauen will
kostenpunkt von marianne timmer erster
monat kosten aber ja wirklich dass es
tatsächlich den ersten monat kostenlos
danach kostet 7 95 was wirklich absolut
fair ist wenn man das mit anderen
streaming anbieter im vergleich dann ist
der preis ähnlich klosters ja noch
fernsehen dabei also ich find das echt
fährt und will ich das euch eigentlich
sagen dass wirklich ein cooles angebot
und bei mir war es halt wie gesagt auch
schon pharma so dass ich wirklich gerne
was im fernsehen gesehen hätte aber für
mich lohnt sich einfach kein
fernsehanschluss und dann ist so
internet-tv einfach so meine gute lösung
was hier wird bei dir 13 herausgebracht
[Musik]
kommen wir so unbekannt war
aber cech auf jeden fall
[Musik]
wenn man meinen eigenen server
doktorvaters kriegt dafür ein punkt
jetzt oder hat mir gefallen
einigen wir uns einen punkteabzug für
dich das nachdenken ja ok 23
[Musik]
sag mir wie vor absolut richtig am 8
ich habe keine ahnung es ist wieder das
sowieso
der juso was den kern von bohlen nicht
in der löhnberger durch ein einschreiben
23 liv und mary j
nicht ein einziges mal gehört
[Applaus]
alles ist relativ
[Musik]
ein klarer fast das ist das eine
diese roboter kämpfen was ist das für
ein ganzes und dieses gehört fa-cup
räuber und gangster gerda und verbrecher
schlagen egal was nicht ja ich weiß ja
tatort nahe aber es hat sich gerade in
meinem kopf schon der gedanke geformt
walter nein sendung mit der maus
[Applaus]
[Musik]
leute ich glaube nach dieser
erniedrigung kann ich mich nicht mehr
retten
sebastian hat zurecht 3 2 gewonnen ich
hatte zwar zwischenzeitlich auch schon
drei punkte aber der wind geht an dieser
stelle an sebastian normal dickes
dankeschön an telekom für die
unterstützung ich werde jetzt erstmal
auf die skipiste gehen und da mit meiner
magenta tvf fernsehturms was man halt so
macht schaut rein